welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and you can try to resist
try to hide from my fist but you know
but you know that you can fight the Moon
Knight come on the first episode of the
Marvel Disney Plus show is now out and
if it left you scratching your head then
this is the video for you throughout it
we're going to be breaking down
everything you need to know about Moon
Knight including his powers gadgets and
best comic book runs I have done a video
on the character before but no one likes
to milk topics more than your Uncle
Kevin spoilers and hopefully this has
enough new info in it that you don't
mind not like you were doing anything
anyway you're sitting about watching
mediocre YouTube videos what are you
complaining about now the show plants is
firmly in the perspective of Steven
Grant a lowly Museum staff member who
has trouble sleeping at night but what
are his hopes his dreams when he can get
them well weirdly Marvel went outside
the box by introducing us to him first
and in the source material Mark is
actually the main Persona Steven is
being changed up quite a bit and in the
comics he's a social actually Playboy
who's basically Marvel centered to Bruce
Wayne over the decades Moon Knight has
drawn a lot of comparisons to Batman and
when he was first created I think it's
fair to say that they were very similar
as time's gone though they've slowly
branched out from this and marble very
much used the character almost as a
mental health study he initially started
off as just one man acting as Stephen
when the time called for it but this has
been developed to go way beyond that
more modern takes of Mark actually
suffering from did or dissociative
identity disorder this means that he has
multiple personalities who all take over
his body and he regularly Cuts between
them if you've seen split then you know
what to expect and Mark is one of the
most broken superheroes in comic book
history now along with Mark and Steven
we also have the Persona of Jake lockley
in the comics he's a cab driver who uses
his connections to underworld crime to
gain Intel for Mark then there's of
course the personas of Moon Knight and
Mr Knight which are very much extensions
of the personalities that all inhabit
Mark's Body now Moon Knight AKA Mark
Specter originally appeared in werewolf
finite 32 all the way back in 1975. he
was co-created by Doug Moen and Don
perlin in what was a devilish debut Mark
was a mercenary that was working for the
highest bidder in order to take down the
titular character by day or night now he
arrived on the scene with several
weapons including badons Spike gloves
and his signature thrown device the moon
rang always annoy me when I hear that as
Moon orang would be better but by the
end of the issue Mark and werewolf by
Knight realize it's all one big
misunderstanding and they decide to
become friends although he was
originally meant to appear in just a
one-off the character was extremely
popular and thus they decided to bring
him back I don't know how they judged if
a side character was popular back then
as they didn't have the internet to
gauge fan interest but maybe it's like
when you show one of your YouTube videos
to your mother and she's like well this
is the best video I've ever seen you
should be on TV with that nasally voice
everyone middle of it now editors Mark
Wolfman and lenween decided to start
placing him into other arcs and they
switched him from a villain to a hero
which is where we're pretty much at
today now Mark Story begins in Chicago
Illinois born the son of a rabbi he and
his father had a strained relationship
due to his strict upbringing oh The
Heirs is the secondary personas have
been retconned to be part of his did
they have kind of reintroduced them
during his childhood Stephen even
appeared as an imaginary friend and
because Mark wasn't allowed to have many
Pals this Persona was very much created
in order to keep him occupied now in
some runs Mark believed that his dad was
a coward because he fled the east in
order to escape the Holocaust during the
second world war Marx stated that he
should have remained in Ford and this
led to him enrolling in boxing classes
before he switched his attention to the
U.S Marine Corps Specter was the best of
the best of the best sir and he left the
Marines in order to become a gun for
hire working as a mercenary he carried
out several backup jobs for the CIA and
gained the nickname more Canary hey he
didn't edit that out edit that out now
Mark was selected for a job out in Egypt
and along with another mercenary name
Ralph Bushman they traveled out to dig
site this was filled with archaeologists
that had Unearthed the Temple dedicated
to the Moon God conchu realizing that it
would make him Rich Beyond his Wildest
Dreams Bushman killed most of the people
there and he ended up beating the crap
out of Mark he left him behind to die at
the side but Mark was found by the
locals who worshiped the God and they
took him before their Shrine in the
world between the living and the dead
konshu appeared to Mark and he was like
all right mate I'll let you live if
you're my avatar on Earth and that'll be
that now like most people Mark agreed to
this and he wrapped himself in the
silver Shard of the statue which was
when Moon Knight was born more caught up
to bishman and he got revenge for what
he did at the Dig Bushman has remained a
major antagonist in the Moonlight books
over the years and though there's been
no news of him being in the series he is
integral to Mark's origin story now
after this he returned to America became
a crime fella and through blackest day
in darkest night nobody can fight my man
night now alongside boxing Specter is
also trained in the Arts of ninjutsu
waitai Judo Kung Fu and karate because
of his training he's able to perform at
an Olympic level and he's also a master
in acrobatics thus traversal around the
city is very easy for him namuna
originally didn't have any superpowers
but over the years he's become more and
more skilled to the point that his
abilities border on the supernatural
judging by what the character does in
the trailers for the series it seems
like he's going to have enhanced
abilities as such as increased strength
Speed and Agility man also does a killer
Dick Van Dyke impression and the guy has
got it all going on now Mark is at a
very hot and cold relationship with
konshu much like what we see in the show
at several points he's disobeyed the
guard and was even stripped of his
powers and left crippled this happened
in the book the bottom and he even cut
off bushman's face at one point in it he
was a fully broken man and he begged for
a second chance from the god which was
eventually granted there's also a lot of
theories that Mark might have actually
imagined entire thing and that conchu
never came to him and he's just
hallucinating his whole life it's a
fascinating aspect of the character and
there's a lot of books that delve into
his mental health now if you want
something to read for the character then
chances are you gotta get a bit lost
there's so many runs that are just
called Moonlight vol 1 and because of
this it's difficult to know where to
start personally I recommend picking up
werewolf by Knight 32 and one of the
classic collections that contains not
only this but also some of the first
stories involving the character though
the origin story of Moon Knight isn't
essential reading it is interesting to
see how it's been modified over the
years it's also the incredible Jeff
Lemire run that you can pick up in a
complete collection this follows Mark as
he's trapped in what appears to be a
psychiatric hospital that he's
apparently been in since he was a kid
he's very much a 12 Monkeys vibe to it
where he's not sure if he's a Moon
Knight or if he imagined it like all the
doctors say eventually it's revealed to
actually being avoid outside of time and
space overseen by konshu who wants to
destroy Mark mentally so that he can can
ReDiscover himself there's some amazing
both wall breaking moments and as he
jumps between his personalities the
environment shift around him when he's
Stephen he believes it's all just a TV
show that he's filming and that he's an
actor taking part in a psychological
drama that's called Moonlight when he's
in Jake mode he's on the streets of
Chicago helping police to solve crimes
when he's Moon Knight he's a fighter
pilot that works on the moon and his
call sign is well Moonlight lots of
incredible moments and I definitely
recommend that you pick it up at the end
he ends up joining all his personalities
together and they come as one to crush
the skull of konshu now it's revealed in
the burger that konju had his eyes on
him ever since he was a kid and in some
stories he's merely shown as a
manifestation of the god called a
Pathfinder these who appeared over the
years and it's going to be interesting
to see if the show tries to tackle
something like this now with the
eternals post credit scene it's also
possible that we could see a formation
of the Midnight Sun soon and potentially
Dane Whitman Moon Knight and blade could
team up together they've all had Big
scenes in London museums and actually
the team could be formed in a
post-credits scene for the series
leading into the blade movie that's
coming down the line anyway that's
everything you need to know Moonlight
and I'd love to hear your thoughts on
the show in the comments below we are a
competition right now giving away three
copies of Spider-Man now we held on the
15th of April and all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one on screen right now said
that to you then message me on Twitter
at heavy spoilers he wants emails to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the first episode which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over all the Easter eggs you could find
in it talk about some of our theories
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you're interested in the show without
the way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been Paul I'll see you next
time take care peace